now ladies and gentlemen it is time to  present the award for best story and  screenplay  I've seen many actors who couldn't act  their way out of a telephone booth but  this guy did mr. Ernest Borgnine  for a best story and screenplay  the winner is interrupted melody  to everybody who worked in this picture  thank you  before you go away yeah Marty what do  you feel like doing tonight I don't know  what do you feel like doing well no what  do you feel like doing I don't know what  do you feel like doing  that's pretty girls around Susan Hayward  Grace Kelly yeah  Audrey Hepburn you think they'd go out  with us what do you feel like doing  right I think I'm gonna return the suit  and go back to the butcher shop